[Music]
hello
for the last couple of years we at
journey to the micro cosmos
have been taking you into a world that
is
our world and yet is also another world
invisible
but beautiful easy to ignore but wildly
dramatic
beneath our notice but vital
we invite people into that world through
our videos
but now we want to invite people to take
their own journeys
and to share them we
in partnership with our master of
microscopes james have developed a
microscope
designed for content creation instead of
just staring with your eyes take
advantage
of the marvelous cameras that we all
have
on our cell phones both to view the
micro cosmos
and to record it so you can share your
discoveries with the rest of the world
one of the most common questions we get
is what microscope
should you buy but it turns out that's a
complicated question
filters objectives eyepieces condensers
and we think you should know about all
of that but it's not as simple
as just linking to a microscope that's
the best option
after all the body of a microscope is
just a stand
it's the things you tack on to it that
make it great
and so we wanted to build something we
think
is a great base level microscope and
also
provide some options to tack onto it
depending on your goals
the first of these options is a set of
oblique illumination
and dark field filters oblique
illumination
can add a sense of depth to your image
while dark field microscopy
highlights samples on a dark background
rather than a light background
and there's also an option for a set of
reinberg filters
these can make your images more dramatic
by adding color
or color gradients and then for our
highest perk level
in addition to including the achromatic
lenses we will also include a set
of plan objectives an achromatic lens
will have more distortion and the outer
35
of the field of view while the plan
objectives reduce that distortion
to only the outer 5 plant objectives
are more expensive because they have
twice as many little lenses packed
inside doing the work
of decreasing operations but the
cheapest microscope we have
available here uses the same lenses
as the ones we filmed our first episodes
of journey to the micro cosmos on
so all of these options are wonderful
options
also remember microscopy is about a lot
more than just
equipment great work can be done without
going all in
and the parts of microscopy that aren't
microscopes
well there's a lot of them and we can
help with that as well
sample collection taking care of
cultures identification of microbes
all part of the game and so we've worked
with james to create a short booklet
that gives an introduction to all of
these things which is included on its
own
or with all of our other perk levels
and of course we're doing all of this
with the hope that you will find
things that you will want to share with
your friends with the internet
and with us frankly we can only discover
so much alone
so we wanted to give you a head start
and push you in the right direction
we cannot wait to see what you find
you